you know there's a lot of
self-flagellation there's a lot of
feeling and certainly a lot of feeling
in the public of the credibility of the
media has deteriorated and I you know I
think some of that is you know we're at
a time of war and if you really look
back at the history of this I think it's
important to do you know the American
media has never been good with war in a
free society with a national interest in
a military and a free press is very hard
to balance all these things it always
has been and actually I would argue that
in most ways that count in many ways the
American media has gotten better over
time has evolved has not gone worse at
all I mean look my in-laws were my my
mother-in-law and and her entire family
were interned during the Second World
War in an American concentration camp
and my my father-in-law fought for a
segregated army unit to try and win
their release which never happened and
during the course of that time over a
hundred thousand japanese-americans that
the heyday of the great you know
Roosevelt II in America more than
100,000 japanese-americans of America
were rounded up and put it against the
president's award I mean there wasn't a
peep out of the American press right you
can't tell me that we've gotten worse
you can't tell me that you know that was
a golden moment Vietnam Ian we remember
about Vietnam a handful of
correspondents who you know who
courageously told the truth about what
they saw the the real picture of course
it's very different the vast majority of
America meeting for years and years was
was was very timid about that war and in
fact you know a lot of those journalists
we now think of as heroes of the Vietnam
era they couldn't get their stuff
printed for a large pretty time so the
in the larger sweep I think the American
media you know has has gotten better and
I think we have a lot to be proud of but
we you know we go through difficult
moments and I think we're in a difficult
moment and I think you know the most
precious commodity you have is the trust
of the public and to the extent that we
squander that you know it does have
long-term ramifications and we have such
a diversification of media now that it's
it's very difficult because people have
to understand that you know Access
Hollywood does not do what I do and part
of it is the responsibility of the
consumers